hahahaha
welcome to know in case let's play some
soccer physics so this is the easiest
game ever you really just click one
button there's security pie my lovin
you're full but some I'm right it's
better than nothing
I'm right in your life and you're
breakdancing and oh whoa that's some
serious breakdancing the thing about
this game breakdancing never wins us I'm
Swedish Brazilian look at me
nice one I don't take of my belly my
nipple belly okay okay Oh Oh God do
something instead of dancing oh we're
just gonna go I like on my legs like I'm
a shark
we're secretly alligators in this game i
won i won
but rematch because you suck swedish
brazilian guy come on nom nom nom nom
secret crocodile this game should be
called yeah yes oh you can't drink like
this it's okay no nom nom nom nom
oh my god I'm so good this gave me like
pure luck I swear to God
no no yeah yeah yeah so good no no no no
no this game is a bull crapper now we
have tiny goals you're never gonna score
don't know yeah oh yeah man he's
protecting with his balls
can I come on again I'm protecting the
ball forever oh you remember score ever
yeah yeah I would
what is this just your get going come on
oh come on nothing is happening you have
to move too
my name is Lange Oh
nice ball now yes
no there's something new yes son
scissors aah whoa calm down calm down
you cray-cray Scizor say sorry this game
should be called soccer Sizzix I try
oh we're system in each other come on
miss scissor it's awkward come on come
on yes is it just me girl okay fine oh
there's two beach balls that's crazy
okay wait whoever wins this one wins
everything in life that's how bad you
are thank I can again play link - no
don't Susan Oh where's that ball gonna
go Who am I in his balls oh okay now
charger charger Wow
yeah yeah yeah huge girl yeah
yeah I'm taking it if they're only ready
dancing bread damn Jake come on Brazil
now yeah what is it do and what advance
my name is racist so hard it's racist
where's my guys doing
attack shock attack now Timo's black
what this game is bullcrap ur settings I
was faking the nose and evil two buckets
forever oh we can play with two bunnies
out let's try that I see you come from
come come control 1 yeah okay
whoever wins this one wins ticket to
Justin Bieber concert I don't want to
thank you
come on don't lie mm-hmm come on I won
cheap - what are you what are you doing
up there what is it legs to it yeah what
is the legs the one sorry tell me you
want it you won what I'm pissing you
with my dick oh I don't know but I was
gonna say it just happened no no no
shark attack Sean just mesh I win
everything ever no it was for the other
one okay this one this one okay
absolutely last one
my guys playing really
okay seriously see I always make you
think that I'm not good at it then you
say that sentence oh I'm sure that to be
zero how do you explain that I felt the
pain in that one trying to jump out of
the bounce my guy left me now what sorry
I helped you with our foolish head don't
self go don't what is he doing no my
guys just want to be acrobats that's why
they're not playing they don't want to
be football players like if you like
everything in life but if you just like
like no one's gonna ever dislike this
video no wait
no one's gonna ever like no I brofist if
you brofist
brofist